whether you're a longtime fan of kate
kane or relatively new to the character
you've come to the right place here's
what we know about the CW's upcoming air
over superhero show bat woman who's in
it
what it's about and why you should start
getting excited go to Gotham City that
woman is set to premiere on October 6
2009 teen followed by the fifth season
premiere of Supergirl serving up a
double dose of DC's most badass women if
you're looking to catch up before she
sets off on her own adventures that
woman has already appeared on a few of
the CW's other superhero shows she
appeared in the Elseworlds crossover
event which played out across ODEs of
arrow the flash and Supergirl in
December of 2018 and served to introduce
Ruby Rose's take on the character to the
TV audience we aren't sure how tied into
these shows Batwoman will be since that
crossover involved dipping into
alternate universes but being set on
parallel worlds hasn't stopped the flash
and Supergirl from hanging out so it
might be worth checking in one of the
big reveals there was that while Batman
does exist in the version of Gotham City
that were seen in Batwoman The Dark
Knight has been mysteriously absent for
quite some time leading a vigilante void
in a city full of super criminals right
from the start the odds are stacked
against bad woman but clearly she's up
for the task The CW has released a ton
of footage for bat woman online but in
May we got a first look trailer that
might just give us the best idea of what
we can expect right away were introduced
to the crows Gotham City's private
mercenary police force established in
the wake of Batman's departure it
appears they aren't quite as effective
as the Batman however as they are
quickly picked off by bat woman central
antagonist Alice a ruthless criminal and
Lewis Carroll fan rachel's Karsten looks
like she's really enjoying the role of
the unhinged Alice which should make her
a fun villain to watch there's a long
history of DC characters who have gone
by the name bad woman but the one we
know today Kate Kane has only existed
for a little over a decade having first
appeared in 2006 in the comics Kate Kane
as Bruce Wayne's cousin but her
childhood was arguably even worse than
his at the age of 12 she was kidnapped
by a cult alongside her mother Gabrielle
and twin sister Beth the cult murdered
Gabrielle and seemingly Beth as
well with Kate as a witness to the
tragedy giving her a similar trauma to
her famous bat relative as an adult Kate
went through West Point hoping to join
the army but was kicked out under Don't
Ask Don't Tell as a lesbian she was
inspired to continue to fight for
justice by Batman himself using fear to
intimidate criminals but operating
mostly on her own using her military
training and technology it could be easy
to dismiss Alice as bat woman's Joker
because well that's basically what she
is she is a Gotham City crime boss
commanding a massive web of criminals
and she's more than a bit unhinged she's
also a skilled fighter welcome back to
Boston Kate she's obsessed with Alice in
Wonderland though her comics iteration
is not tied to the Mad Hatter or his
gang the comics have a few interesting
twists about the connection between
Alice and bat woman
no spoilers for the uninitiated but
we'll see if the show picks those up
while we know a few of the characters we
can expect to see The CW is keeping a
pretty tight lid on the plot of bat
woman's first season obviously we're
going to see Kate Cain's transformation
into Gotham's protector and judging from
the trailer it seems like Alice is going
to be the villain who forces her into
becoming Gotham City's new bat themed
hero along with Alice the CW has
confirmed that two other comic villains
are coming to the first season of bad
woman but we don't know how big a role
they'll play magpie who is also used as
a minor villain in the final season of
Gotham will be showing up in at least
one episode season 1 will also introduce
Tommy Elliot who later becomes hush we
can also expect a few ties between bat
woman and the larger Batman universe
for example Kate Caine's tech guru is
the son of Lucius Fox that said it seems
unlikely that the Dark Knight will ever
appear in bat woman at least for a while
Ruby Rose has played plenty of badass
characters before stepping into the role
of bat woman the Australian actress is
probably best known for orange is the
new black but she's also shown up in
plenty of other big-time action
franchises like xxx and John wick Rose
is interesting casting in a lot of ways
but one particularly noteworthy pieces
that Rose who identifies as gender-fluid
and a lesbian is playing the first
openly gay suit
our hero lead to come to film or
television a huge part of that woman's
origin story is her dismissal from West
Point after being outed rather than
avoid this aspect of the character The
CW is fully embracing it putting Kate
Kane's sexuality front and center Ruby
Rose has spoken extensively about her
struggles with identity growing up and
how she hopes she can be a positive
influence through her success she said
in interviews that she wants Batwoman to
be the kind of show that would have made
her life better if she'd had it when she
was a teenager showing a hero who can
make some changes in the real world to
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite DC heroes are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]